I want chocolate babies - oh yes
I just think they're funny and also I
think I have a better chance of not
having to pay for college because I get
a scholarship I've been trying to get
pregnant stop it these are good people
watching right now Milo
excited to bring on our next guest was
supposed to be on last week violently
ill my lowly innopolis thanks for being
on sir Thank You angel how oh my gosh
three I didn't not get your didn't
reveal until look at you look at the new
pump you going rockabilly oh well I do I
think you're kind of stealing my my
style
you think I'm Justine I've never had
another haircut I hate that it's now
trendy is this your haircut is this what
you have like pretty much except I just
don't overdo it
if I were trolling the bars I would I
would do it like yours the problem is
now when I go in I say listen give me
this and they go oh when they try and
cut it like yours because that's the
trend I'm like no no I don't want it as
exaggerated yours isn't exact you dope a
you know I just wake up like yes I mean
other people tell me stories about hours
spent in the salon I just wake up and I
look like well you were coughing up a
lung from some seafood poisoning from
what you told me so hopefully you're
feeling better
I had well I went for a very beautiful
meal which was a lovely tasting my new
yada-yada
but I think the oysters were maybe a bit
bad so I was supposed to be on I was
special eating a pre-record with you and
I was kind of like spontaneously having
stomach convulsions on the side of the
motorway so I'm sorry we didn't get to
do that but hey you got me live even
better we'll talk about that afterward
so rough week for you Milo it's a what a
rough week I saw your tweets when Trump
lost the caucus you were not throw daddy
no no no daddy's fine daddy's fine
listen nobody cares about Iowa nobody
gives a [ __ ] about it they haven't
picked a nominee since 2000 this goes
out to FCC stations so let's keep the
language - uh that's you I know what you
guys do when you're seedy little gay
bars with your bugchasers deplorable and
disgusting homosexual it is dependable
hey can you can you for once do you
think I'm a [ __ ] servant of Milo yes but
I am too so it's okay really you are -
yeah no no I mean some of the people who
use that word like me but I still am one
I did it I did a test there's like a
seven question kept like a questionnaire
and I think like strong support for
Israel like immediately puts you in the
[ __ ] servitude box so I'm as well
and I think being a [ __ ] doesn't help
advance what else there's some other
thing that I believe in that they don't
like Oh like I suppose I would be
probably kind of neocon on foreign
policy because I'm quite hawkish so I
think you get a pastor because you're
flamboyantly gay yes I think I think
that all right whoo I have many
sympathies with by the way I like him in
many ways I think they tend to be fairly
anti-war anti expansionism and except
they love Hitler well I think that most
of you know I think that the press has
completely got that Ron oh I'm done with
my timeline right now is literally
nothing but pro-hitler comments from the
alt-right but they do it because it gets
you they didn't get to me at all they do
it because they support Hitler it's got
to you because you know you're bringing
it out look these people are
professional like professional trolls on
the Internet
why do this enjoy your connection no why
do they send jonah goldberg of national
review like horrible things about jews
because he never shuts up about it when
they do people don't troll because it
doesn't work you know people troll
because they get under people's skin and
they fly off the handle you gotta
remember most this is like a lot of
these like a 17 year old kids for God's
sake um and they didn't they don't have
any living relatives who through the
Second World War they don't appreciate
you would of course say there's nothing
wrong with me saying I would adopt a
black child why would there be anything
wrong no they're like oh you're a kook
how dare you I want chocolate babies too
oh I just think they're funny and also I
think have a better chance of not having
to pay for college because I get a
scholarship stop it
these are good people watching right now
Milo's I love it when Americans pretend
to understand European languages well I
was raised in Canada I spoke color with
a u so I'm a half-breed I remember this
this is why I'd never come on your show
because I don't like appearing in public
with Canadian this is true listen no one
is proud of it okay no one no one's
brought up in Canadian specially now
with with Trudeau oh my gosh so
okay but well I didn't want to interrupt
so what we're where are you feeling this
week you said you feel fine because I
know I know you've talked about Trump
but you even said on the Rogan podcast
you're not really hoping he wins you
like because I'm starting to get really
into I mean the more I find out about
the American Republican establishment
and the American political establishment
generally the more I realize it's just
like ours in London and the more I want
to see it hurt but they endorse price
the more I want to see it suffer no I
mean they're coming they're coming round
to the idea that they might have to
pretend to tolerate him because they
think he's controllable and they don't
think Cruz is but would we though
wouldn't we admit that's kind of a
testament to the fact that Cruz is
pissed so many people off because he
does his own thing whether you like it
or not yeah yeah and and he should wear
that with she'd wear that as a badge of
pride I said anyone yeah yeah for sure
but like a straight version of you no no
no no because he's no there's something
slightly amphibian about Ted Cruz like
if you touched his hands they'd be sort
of clammy and and cold
you can't he's kind of like mr. Roger to
the Dracula's Widow peak I can't warm to
him and I don't know why I think he may
just be like one of those people that
just you can't empathize with he's just
like a brick wall emotionally and I just
can't get inspired by it it's not like
that ease its insight fees no daddy it's
insight from a sociopathic narcissist so
that's a good analyst you know poachers
make the guess the poachers make the
best gamekeeper so I'm just letting you
know I see him as a sort of fellow
associate we'll have Adam how do you see
this playing out in Britain right as
someone who comes in from Europe
Europe's fallen we know that you know
that how do they see are they too close
to the forest to see the trees or do
they see this and go you know what Trump
might be right about some things Brits
don't like Trump because they don't like
the brashness of his particular style of
American like conspicuous consumption
and unapologetic brashness Europeans and
particularly Brits don't like that at
all so that they they sort of
instinctively know they don't like him
and then they search for reasons why
they why they search for reasons they
can say they don't like him that are a
bit more publicly acceptable than I
don't like brash people which is the
truth so they'll say for example was in
Islam
or is a racist or whatever we have this
grotesque terrible spectacle of our MPs
in Parliament wasting taxpayer money and
that's for people like me who you know
I've defended Trump on those issues that
that you know what was it duck from
whatever that that fake social yes he
has the right enemies most of the time
he would get on board the train a bit
more often or at least just acknowledge
this more often because I know you hate
him as this is a serious candidate but I
judge people by their enemies and there
is nobody with the possible exception of
me there annoys the progressive left as
much as the dear sweet daddy well I've
been doing it bad since 2009 when when
Trump was a Democrat and I think I don't
know what you were doing but I pissed
him off for a long time as from we was
against Islamic speech a half yeah about
half a year ago whatever I think I did
if his particular policy positions are
why people vote for him anyway so if
you're trying to interrogate him on the
basis of ideological consistency no I
think you're right I think you're right
if people like I mean I don't understand
pain when you don't understand his
voters if you're trying to interrogate
him according to policy positions that
I'm just I'm at the free speech position
you know it's a Pam Geller thing I think
would be great on point back that I get
the feeling that he's not as robust on
free speech as I would like but I
believe that he can be educated on that
I have had some you know what little he
said for example about technology and
video games which is an area that the
two areas that I'm into his positions
aren't perfect there but that's only
because I think they haven't really been
fleshed out in true through yet um I
think on free speech he's sort of
wavered slightly and as you know I'm a
yes well that's all I want to go before
we go to the break in England Europe is
free speech making a comeback do you
think or is it gone forever no no it
never will only there's a chance in
America because you have the first and
thank God the Second Amendment that
basically protects your rights and your
freedoms that we don't have anything
comparable in Europe we don't have
anything similar and we don't it is on
you're still here congratulations you
win the internet click my face to go to
ladder with Crowder calm or we do news
every single day subscribe on iTunes or
SoundCloud or if you can't be bothered
this clip was taken from a full show you
can click that full
right next to me great guests callers
sketches every single week we livestream
it here Thursday at 8 p.m. also very
rarely do we wear pants in the studio